bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de sept huit sociétés la cyber
criminalité comment y faire face
après les attentats début janvier
certaines collectivités locales ont
découvert les cyber attaques plus de
21000 site français ont été frappés dont
une partie justement de ces
collectivités et on a voulu savoir
comment elles font pour se protéger pour
protéger leurs données quel plan
d'action met elle en place pour contrer
les pirates qui en la matière semble
avoir quand même pris de l'avancé on va
voir ça avec vous avec mes invités en
plateau aujourd'hui 35 à 40% des
collectivités en france seulement j'ai
envie de dire s'occupe de la
cybersécurité pour en parler
deux exemples concrets de cyber
protection d'avoir la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2014
notamment un budget de 200 mille euros
elle dédiée à la sécurité informatique a
été débloqué et nous verrons avec vous
offrez d'erik dietman bonsoir et olivier
derbesse françois à quoi sert ce
financement et les mesures mises en
place nous intéresseront aussi à la
commune de saint cyr l'école avec vous
car evans et guillard bonsoir mon sens
alors dans votre cas on peut peut-être
le dire la donne est simple système
informatique est un peu anciens et vous
êtes en cours de modernisation et
voulait même devenir le fer de lance
dans le département en la matière
effectiveness précaire dans quelques
instants et puis benoît de saint sernin
bonsoir vous allez porter vous un regard
plus large sur la cybercriminalité vous
pourrez certainement donner des conseils
aux uns et aux autres vous êtes le
fondateur du centre des hautes études
sur le cyber espace voudrais d'abord
vous remercier d'être venu en plateau
pour expliquer et témoigner parce que
quand j'ai voulu préparer cette émission
certaines communes nous empresser à
vouloir tout simplement qu'elle n'avait
rien de particulier en matière de
protection informatique d'autres n'ont
pas du tout s'exprimer lorsque j'ai
compris dans les échanges que j'ai eus
avec certaines mairies je ne vais pas
citer bien entendu c'est que j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde n'est pas
la même enseigne en matière de niveau de
sécurité
c'est quelque chose que vous pourriez
vous confirmez ressentir d'écouté oui il
ce chiffre là effectivement il écrit il
et confirme au niveau national nous
d'agglomération nous avons bien sûr
comme toutes les collectivités en charge
de nombreuses applications informatiques
que ce soit en interne ou à l'extérieur
et maintenant on a de plus en plus
besoin de s'ouvrir d'ouvrir notre
informatique nos informations vers les
citoyens les partenaires avec des
portails internet avec le les échanges
informatisés avec nos partenaires avec
les autres sa disgrâce il faut prendre
en compte mais on al'impression toutes
les collectivités prennent pas au même
niveau mais notre sincèrement est-ce que
c'est une réalité ça que c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui est dans
déjà dans les moeurs et non non non
c'est pas dans les moeurs parce que
notre génération a découvert le
numérique on a commencé nos vies
professionnelles pratiquement son
numérique et aujourd'hui on nous oblige
et aussi bien personnelles que dans
l'exercice de nos métiers à tout faire
en numérique et on se rend compte que
finalement c'est un paysage sur lesquels
on n'est absolument pas m il est tenu
par d'autres et c'est un grand espace
aussi de délinquance donc ça prend
différentes formes soit des de la
délinquance qui ramène de l'argent aux
méchants soit de la délinquance comme
vous en avez semble-t-il été victime
madame où on a mis en panne des sites
internet on a cherché à nuire et je sais
pas ce que ça vous est arrivé parce que
vous avez été piraté après les attentats
alors pour le coup nous pas du tout il
ya ainsi deux satellites mais voilà qui
était le site sky gulf en fait mais qui
nous appartenait déjà quasiment plus je
dirais puisque il était être cédées donc
voilà on a été pour une partie mais
c'est vrai que comme on disait nous on a
déjà pris en compte toutes ces
problématiques de sécurité donc on est
un petit peu plus en avance que quand
même que d'autres petits alors à ça
c'est à l'école a été piraté alors à
saint cyr l'école pour l'instant on
constate pas de piratage sur le site
internet il faut savoir que nous à saint
cyr l'école on a quand même un site
internet qui est une ainsi de vitrine en
quelque sorte ce que qu'on parlait tout
à l'heure de portails de service on n'a
pas encore fait ce choix de portails de
service pour n'a tout simplement pas
encore pu allouer les ressources pour ça
on est en pleine transition à saint cyr
l'école et peut-être que plus tard on
on pourra vous expliquer au cours de
l'émission justement la nouvelle
stratégie liés au numérique
allez on va s'intéresser justement à ces
cas concrets on va commencer par la
casse qui parce que effectivement il ya
une réflexion à ses anciennes qui a été
mise en place avec une sécurisation qui
se construit au fur et à mesure c'est
pas le même style avec les différents
volets la sécurité physique la sécurité
autour des accès la protection si des
serveurs pour la sécurisation physique
il faut rappeler que les locaux de
tableau ont déménagé à mons est la
troisième des qui était très jolie mais
qui peut-être ne ferait pas dans ce même
monsieur très joli mais enfin quand même
pas des niveaux de sécurisation et puis
vous avez intégré des anciens locaux
mercedes on n a pu bénéficier déjà d'une
infrastructure existante qui était donc
la salle serveurs de la société hertz
qui était avant avec donc des matériels
notamment au niveau de la climatisation
au niveau du groupe électrogène que l'on
attend tout ça et on a mis en place on a
rénové cette salle et on a mis en place
un contrôle d'accès puisque la sécurité
aussi commence par l'accès à la
protection au niveau des accès physique
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a fait
il ya trois ans et puis après on bien
entendu cette sécurité on l'a construite
au fur à mesure qu'on a qu'on a
construit notre système d'information et
l'année dernière on a procédé on a fait
auditer notre notre système
d'information et sa ville avait
récemment les absences et un bon conseil
à donner aux collectivités servent
encore de passer par un audit baffe
mais il faut à quoi faire après tout si
mais il faut en accepter le résultat
c'est ça c'est bien qu'il faut accepter
le résultat parce que aujourd'hui testé
son installation faire des audits
c'est effectivement important dans la
plupart des cas l'audit montre des
failles et on arrive à un vrai problème
qu'on a dans cet univers numérique c'est
que pour corriger cette faille
il va falloir du budget et est ce que
les gens qui sont soit nos élus enfin je
suis moi même élu mais les élus vont
accepter de débloquer pour quelque chose
qui est parfaitement invisible équipe on
se protège aujourd'hui d'une menace mais
voilà pourquoi la cascade il dit
avant par les lots dit je voudrais juste
dire quand même que les élus le maire ou
le président pour la casse qui sont
pénalement responsables autour de la
protection des données personnelles et
la sécurité la protection des données
personnelles fait partie de la sécurité
donc là il faut aussi sensibiliser nos
élus du riz des risques qu'ils encourent
à être négligents par rapport à aux
moyens qui convenait que les élus sont
pas forcément sensibilisé
je présume que même au sein de la caisse
qu'ils n'étaient peut-être pas forcément
sensibilisé il faut leur falloir
expliquer pour leur expliquer et vous
aussi qui est une culture de la sécurité
informatique qui accompagne toutes ces
mesures physiques que on a mis en place
en amérique face à l'école que le maire
est pénalement responsable français on
sait que parce que j'ai découvert en
préparant un entretien avec évidemment
on le sait on est au courant puisque
justement dans la nouvelle stratégie
numérique de saint cyr l'école on
voudrait justement connecter un petit
peu toutes les personnes de la ville
comme ça se fait énormément c'est une
grande problématique est évidemment la
première problématique et qui arrive
avant ça c'est la preuve vis de la
sécurité de la protection des données
si justement on a conscience que nous
sommes
l'élu responsable il faut justement
qu'on ce qu'on se prémunissent des
risques est effectivement mettre en
place des stratégies qui sont sécurisées
dans tous les sens on va dire donc
d'avoir faire prendre conscience aux
élus qui sont pénalement responsables et
donc c'est aux intérieurs 4 4 comme le
disait monsieur a tout d'ailleurs s'est
effectivement c'est vrai que dans un
audit un site un fail et moi j'y crois
pas c'est il ya toujours des failles qui
existent donc effectivement il ya eu des
failles qui ont été remontés sur pas mal
applicative c'est vrai qu'il faut savoir
qu'on gère une cinquantaine
d'applications voire même plus mais une
cinquantaine de grosses applications et
malheureusement sur ses applications là
il faut savoir que les éditeurs sont pas
tous sensibilisés aux questions de
sécurité donc effectivement il ya
beaucoup de failles qu'on a remonté à
des éditeurs en leur disant bah voilà là
vous avez une faille il faut la corriger
donc j'ai eu des éditeurs qui ont très
bien réagi qui nous ont corrigé les
failles et pour d'autres il a fallu
qu'on passe par des palliatifs qu'on
mette en place des équipements
supplémentaires dès ce qu'on appelle des
firewall applicatif justement qui permet
justement une surcouche pour sécuriser
ses applications sur lesquelles
l'éditeur bas lui
vos pas l'intérêt de modifier son code
parce que pour lui voilà il n'ya pas
deux il n'y a pas d'intérêt on va dire
et c'est vrai que ça cause ça coûte de
l'argent modifier le code aussi pour un
éditeur puisque c'est un développeur à
remettre sur le code etc
voilà donc et vous me disiez l'important
la suite de cet audit c'est aussi
d'abord peut-être d'établir le niveau de
sécurité souhaité parce que on ne peut
pas avoir le niveau de sécurité ont fait
en tout cas c'est peut-être pas
intéressant d'avoir le même niveau de
sécurité que peut avoir une banque qui
peut avoir une collectivité locale
mais on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui quand
même vu la la la diffusion de
l'informatique dans tous les secteurs
l'absence de deux de ces moyens-là à
disposition des citoyens des
utilisateurs internes est un terme au
problème donc il faut savoir
effectivement mesurer les risques et les
enjeux donc l'enjeu comme je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment la
disponibilité du système de formation
donc quels sont les usages qui sont les
plus sensibles que les plus urgents à
mettre en maître en haute sécurité et
puis la protection des données
savoir identifier quelles sont les
données où elles sont stockées qui les
utilisent à qu'elle s'adresse et c'est
ça qui est compliqué c'est toute la
problématique autour de la donner est-ce
qu'elle plus sensible sur pour vous pour
la casse qui sait c'est la lingerie
c'est l'état c'est à dire tous les
services qu'on va dès qu'on va donner au
public donc nous il ya encore le wifi
les postes publics mis à au sein des
médiathèques par exemple voilà tout ce
qui concerne le service public dans une
commune ça peut être tout ce qui est à
civile
voilà donc c'est vraiment ce qui va
concerner le service public et puis
l'image typiquement le sérieux site
institutionnel
voilà sit ins tissu institutionnel et et
d'effacer ce qu'on appelle d'effacer ces
voix là on a supprimé la page classique
voilà ça c'est vraiment pour l'image de
la commune
buts en cas d' attaque ces deux régions
le plus rapidement possible oui on
essaye on essaye il existe dans
certaines entreprises et dans certaines
communes des plans de continuité
d'activité s'il nous arrive ça comment
on se replie mais effectivement comme le
disait très bien madame et c'est un
point important c'est qu'est-ce que je
dois défendre
est ce que c'est la totalité du système
d'information où certains endroits où
sont stockées les données principalement
sur les données qui concernent les
individus que ce soit dans le cadre
public de vos missions publiques ou même
en entreprise
voilà et on se rend compte que ce n'est
pas forcément tout à protéger mais ce
qui est à protéger va réclamer du budget
et c'est un vrai un vrai souci un art d
or justement le budget il est de combien
combien de personnes travaillent au tour
de ceux de cette problématique de
sécurité informatique et bien et on est
une vingtaine dans la direction et donc
avec un pôle opérations justement qui
est notre bolide hervé ce travail donc
qui est notre garant de la sécurité
mais l'ensemble des chefs de projets qui
travaillent avec moi sur la mise en
place de deux d'application sont aussi
doivent respecter aussi
il faut savoir aussi que les
collectivités locales ont aussi des
aides l'état il ya plusieurs structures
qui peuvent aider les collectivités à
aider sur un plan financier des
subventions allant déjà les deux
techniques organisationnelles pour les
aider à mettre en place dans une
application les mesures de ce qui a été
s'imposer à la cnil qui est là pour
aussi les commission nationale
informatique et libertés qui est là pour
donner des conseils quand on met en
place une application
il y aller tu as sorti un règlement de
sécurité le règlement le rgs le
règlement général de sécurité qui doit
qui met en avant les bonnes pratiques à
mettre en place pour les collectivités
et puis il ya aussi la mise en place de
plateformes des changes que l'état a mis
en place des plateformes des charges
avec nos pas avec le les autres
administrations donc avec la préfecture
quatre formes d'échangés sécurisés qui
s'appelle actes de l'état civil comme et
d'hec et pour le trésor public avec la
dématérialisation des échanges des flux
comptables qui s'appelle hélios donc on
voit bien qu ici on n'est quand même pas
devant cette problématique là on peut
essayer de se faire aider de se faire
conseiller par des structures externes
oui je rajouterais même madame vous
l'avez pas citer l'anssi l'agencé
nationale des systèmes de la sécurité
des systèmes d'information où il ya
toute une partie donc c'est accessible
au grand public toute une partie avec
même un guide qu'ils appellent le guide
de l'hygiène informatique qui est
vraiment un très bon outil
ça fait 2 le mémoire il ya 42 ou 46
recommandations si vous atteignez déjà
la quatrième et vous la mettez en oeuvre
c'est un lien mais c'est un remarquable
outil voilà toujours un guide de bonnes
pratiques donc c'est toujours avant de
moi j'suis plus opérationnel un autre là
et c'est vrai que voilà faut toujours
prendre un guide de bonnes pratiques et
voir après ce qu'on arrive à faire dans
l'opération parce que c'est pas toi j'ai
pas simple à mettre en oeuvre a dit si
vous arrivez à la quatrième saison
c'est le diable ça pue ça rassure
certainement en 2014 et mais un budget
de 100 mille euros qui a été qui a été
débloquée on comprend que c'est de
l'argent
il n'y a pas d' aides financières qui
peuvent être apportées aux collectivités
territoriales pour mettre en connexion
oliveres vous avez parlé du wifi
effectivement c'est une question
délicate comment on protège quand on met
le wifi dans les médiathèques par
exemple de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça
veut dire quoi il faut que les gens sans
registre
alors voilà des procédures
d'identification des utilisateurs ça
c'est façon en tant que fournisseur
d'accès puisque l'on se met à la place
d'un fournisseur d'accès on doit à
l'erreur
les obligations clean un c'est de savoir
qui est qui s'authentifie qui se
connectent à internet et qui fait quoi
en gros pour que en cas de recours etc
en cas de demande de police on puisse au
moins donné ça donc il ya déjà toute
cette partie là donc aujourd'hui nous
tous en médiathèque typiquement il ya
les adhérents on les connaît puisqu'il
sont fichés affiché entre nîmes et ils
sont renseignés dans une base et donc on
sait qu'ils se connectent à quelle heure
et qu'est ce qu'il fait sur internet
voilà donc toute la connexion wi-fi
passe par cette authentification là donc
ça peut être une authentification par
nom prénom ça peut être un numéro de
téléphone aujourd'hui avec un numéro de
téléphone est capable de remonter ça les
utilisateurs comme le personnel voit
c'est une bonne à bonneuil housse et
défend un peu mal à tout lui dire mais
normal quand vous dites riches et
d'ailleurs le terme vous avez vous êtes
repris vous avez dit renseigner mais
n'empêche qu'on peut aussi allemands
récente voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on me
l'a dit sans cesse fichiers suivi c'est
un vrai sujet parce que c'est vrai qu'en
médiathèque
au départ quand on est arrivé un petit
peu et toutes ces contraintes puisque
avant on offrait de l'internet un petit
peu ouvert à tout le monde et c'est là
on a commencé à dire non non nous toute
connexion à internet doit être
nominatives
et là c'est vrai que ça a posé plein de
questions de savoir comment on allait
s'organiser ce que les gens allaient pas
voilà se sentir impliqué parce que y'a
aussi mais voilà c'est bon maintenant on
commence à ça commence à rentrer dans
les moeurs entre guillemets parce que ce
serait quand même beaucoup de on voit
bien beaucoup de hacking de compte
twitter de est une affaire snowden quand
même qu'ils qui a révélé beaucoup
beaucoup de choses que la nsa écoute
tout ce qu'on fait et arbres il ya
beaucoup il ya pas que la casse qui non
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que on
est dans un milieu comme on disait tout
numérique et il faut qu'on sache un
petit peu qu'on puisse se prémunir de
deux problématiques et ça c'est quelque
chose à faire intégrer aussi dans
l'esprit des gens qui pleurent s'est
offert la sphère snowdon est vraiment
dans l'histoire du numérique cia il ya
une cassure c'est à dire que là on a
parfaitement compris dans le cadre du
che si et de l'école d'intelligence
économique on travaille avec les
services de l'état là dessus à partir de
la sphère snowdon on a compris qu'en
fait les américains avaient une vraie
stratégie pour contrôler tout le
numérique si je fais un parallèle avec
l'électricité c'est comme si aujourd'hui
la france acheter son électricité à un
pays étranger et que il ya que ce pays
qui nous fournit dans le numérique fait
ça et donc les américains ne nous laisse
pas libre
dès qu'on se connexion numérique en est
chez eux et y contrôle alors un des
outils pour essayer d'être libre
c'était le cryptage des communications
des infos etc
la sphère snowden nous a montré
qu'ils sont capables d'être de casser
les cryptes des choses importantes donc
on est des cons se connectent on est
chez eux faut en être conscient et
psychologiquement c'est très compliqué
aussi bien sur l'aspect étatique des
choses que sur nos vies privées
dès qu'on se connecte on est chez eux on
n'est pas chez nous donc on a vu au
niveau de la castille attaques de choses
qui se sont mises en place alors ne
tourne vers vous car une guerre alors au
niveau de saint cyr l'école mais je me
trompais on m'a guidé en préparant les
missions que le système informatique
était un peu anciens en fait dire ça
comme ça et qui avait beaucoup de choses
à faire évoluer vous êtes vous avez été
nommé après les élections municipales et
vous êtes en charge de ce dossier là
elle m'a même dit on veut faire de ce
que saint cyr l'école soit le fer de
lance dans le département en la matière
c'est très ambitieux salués après voilà
comment démarre démarre d'assez bas il
faut il faut le reconnaître on a envie
justement que saint cyr l'école puisse
un petit peu s'élever à l'eau recommandé
mardi de base c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit en gros le site internet c'est
pour aujourd'hui le site internet ça
reste une vitrine pour la ville on n'a
pas de justement on propose pas de
services liés à site internet par
exemple de paiement en ligne
ce qu'on peut voir sur des sites un à
deux pas mal de villes par exemple des
frais de cantine qui seraient payés par
les parents on n'a pas encore cette
possibilité là et parce que cette
possibilité il ya un risque
il ya une orientation stratégique a été
prise dans les années 2000 par
l'ancienne équipe une des anciennes
équipes la personne qui était
responsable de l'informatique à l'époque
qui a décidé justement de faire quelque
chose de basique pour accès justement
cette problématique sur la sécurité nous
maintenant ce qu'on voudrait faire c'est
bien sûr approcher une une réaction sur
le long terme et pas surtout pas du
court terme puisque on sait que
l'informatique je pense que je vous
dirai pas le contraire cela nécessite
des projets sur le long terme
on voudrait écrire en compte et surtout
que c'est une évolution en continu sans
arrêt voilà moi rien n'est jamais acquis
non rien n'est acquis justement et on
voudrait basé notre projet tout le
concept sur la sécurité
vous parliez de pca paiera nous
justement on voudrait commencer par par
essayer de voir si on peut mettre en
place un per à 10,6 à entre signalé oui
oui mais c'est pas ta ferme c'est être
laissé les experts décrivent le mieux
que moi le côté technique
mon père a plan de reprise d'activité
des serbes pour une continuité
d'activité en fait c'est voilà combien
de temps on est capable de voilà de
reprendre ou même continuer l'activité
même en cas de coupure tout simplement
donc du coup la problématique de
sécurité pour nous sera importante
en premier lieu évidemment ensuite on va
essayer de axé notre future stratégie
sur tout ce qui est accessibilité donc
l'accessibilité justement ça comprend
tout ce qui est paiement en ligne
ça aussi c'est un exemple après on peut
relier l'accessibilité aussi à la
formation du personnel de la mairie on
en parlait tout à l'heure avant
l'émission
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important puisque les personnes devant
le personnel de la mairie n'est pas
forcément familier justement de tout ce
qui est numérique
donc il ya un gros travail de formation
offertes dans ce dans ces institutions
là il s'avise a justement améliorer tout
ce qui est accessibilité et j'en viens à
1 2 un autre de nos axes qui est
vraiment nous tient à coeur nous c'est
tout ce qui est économie et
rationalisation et on pourrait emmener
ces personnes là justement à changer
leurs habitudes elle pouvoir passer
complètement des documents numérisés et
sortir de la sphère dépenses de passe et
c'est là la grande ambition ces migrants
non non non enfin je dis c'est très
ambitieux non mais c'est pas que je
crois pas c'est que c'est le
raisonnement sur lequel on est parti au
moment du début de la numérisation c'est
que ça allait faire permettre plein
d'économies plein de choses et on le
voit même dans la vie économique
aujourd'hui les experts comptables sont
obligés de télédéclarer à bercy pour
gagner du temps et en fait on met sur le
numérique
des centaines et des milliards
d'informations qu'on maîtrise plus du
tout est en fait le coût de sa est bien
supérieur à soi disant l'économique au
rejet que devait générer ce genre
d'outil donc en fait dans le cadre de
chessy du centre des hautes études sur
le cyberespace
on travaille sur cette transformation
numérique est en fait l'idée de se dire
ça va être une économie grâce à ça non
c'est un nouveau c'est un nouvel usage
parce qu'on est né avec ça on va
l'utiliser mais pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune étude qui montre que son on a
fait des économies
tellement il ya de conséquence dès que
ça dérape pour améliorer votre système
informatique ce que vous allez mettre en
place un audit comme évidemment
nous dit c'est ça représente un coût
donc pour l'instant nous on n'a que ça
représente la télé ça représente aussi
tout une réflexion après les faits son
cercle on est complètement dans la
sphère numérique en ce moment et on a
besoin de faire cet audit c'est vital
d'une part pour tout ce qui est
infrastructure propre à la mairie est
propre aux sites distants qui sont
reliés à la mairie et ensuite nous mêmes
problématiques on va complètement
refondre le site internet et là on aura
aussi besoin de faire un audit pour
comprendre tous les besoins aussi bien
du personnel que des habitants c'est ça
c'est un plan qui s'étale sur combien de
temps c'est un plan qui s'étale sur six
ans comme je vous ai dit sur une
mandature ça va être assez ambitieux de
le faire sur six ans évidemment parce
que ça nécessite l'injection d'argent
qui est assez on va dire importante et
mais c'est vrai que c'est une
problématique nous tient à coeur et
justement j'ai été nommé en ce sens pour
essayer de mener à bien cette politique
on essayera d'avoir le plus de résultats
possibles dans les années à venir
un dernier axe qu'on va développer aussi
c'est toute la sphère innovation on en
parlait avant l'émission toute la
problématique de la fibre dans les
yvelines qui est un sujet qui est très
houleux et très compliqué je pense que
on va peut-être pas trop s'étendre là
dessus parce que nous par exemple saint
cyr l'école il était prévu que quand on
est là qu on puisse bénéficier de la
fibre en 2016 entre 2016 et 2017
visiblement on va subir quelques retards
je crains c'est je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur deux points d'ailleurs on a
parlé des portails payant pour la casse
qui notamment il ya des sites qui est
qui et qui permet une billetterie c'est
le site du kiosque commencé protéger ce
site
comment on peut être sûr que quand on va
prendre un billet sur le site du kiosque
on aura pas de souci alors déjà ce
projet fait intervenir de nombreux
composants que ça soit des composants
techniques et des composants
informatiques et nous sommes quand même
la fin du dispositif la fin de l'acte
d'achat passe par partenaires qui
s'appelle p box et qui est donc un
partenaire qui est sécurisé donc on a
confiée à un partenaire cette sécurité
au niveau du du delà du paiement du
paiement proprement dit mais nous avons
aussi les une surveillance du
systèmes d'information et une
surveillance aussi ce qu'on appelle une
cartographie du système d'information
qui nous permet aussi de vérifier que
l'ensemble des process se passe aussi
dans de bonnes conditions c'est aussi ça
la sécurité c'est aussi la garantie de
garantir que la donner et n'est pas
vérolé n'est pas modifiée d'une façon
aléatoire et que en garantie les
traitements garantir le traitement alors
autre question ça concerne le
financement on comprendre tout ça coûte
cher
est ce que demain on peut envisager une
mutualisation par exemple où chaque
copains vous êtes une communauté
d'agglomération ça sert l'école vous
fait aussi partie d'une communauté
d'agglomération de versailles à grands
pas et lui à versailles ne peut pas le
nier est ce que ça veut dire que les
collectivités aujourd'hui doivent se
mettre ensemble pour mutualiser ses
moyens est ce qu'une ville tout seul a
les moyens de financer une sécurisation
ton système parce que c'est souhaitable
tout dépense tout dépend l'ambition que
nous aurons avec cet outil
si c'est effectivement un outil pour
tout dématérialisé pouvoir payer comme
le proposait monsieur tout à l'heure la
crèche les exeter et c'est là ça va
devenir très cher si par exemple dans
les centres de vgp versailles grand parc
il ya dix-neuf communes six et dix neuf
mois 19 fois le même système c'est idiot
maintenant un système commun c'est un
césar et moi aussi
voilà qui nous avait un pacte et tout le
monde à la fin donc à jadriya différente
je pense qu'il faut vraiment mais vous
l'avez très bien victor madame faire la
séquence de caisse qui est vraiment à
protéger et voilà et on se rendra compte
qu'il ya finalement pas tant de choses
que ça et peut-être que ces choses là
ces services là par exemple des services
de paiements à distance e peuvent être
centralisées à l'échelle d'une
communauté d'agglo et on va mettre un
petit peu de budget de chacune des
communes pour s'assurer de sa après les
sites vitrines qui donne les horaires de
la mairie etc
bon ok ils peuvent être attaqués c'est
pas dramatique c'est un risque qu'on
peut pour vous partager sur le schéma de
mutualisation qu'on met en oeuvre la qui
doivent être votées par les élus en mars
eh bien on a effectivement des axes
l'informatique est un axe majeur pour
les schémas de mutualisation et on voit
bien qu'on va nous travailler sur d'une
part des propositions de mutation
physique de salles etc mais aussi
tous deux compétences de compétences et
d'expérience qu'on peut partager pour
faire gagner du temps et gagner du temps
à nos collègues dans les collectivités
un dernier mot pour donner l'exemple en
termes de compétences sur l'île de
france aujourd'hui il y à 1200 postes
ouverts de gens en charge de
cybersécurité on ne trouve pas les
jeunes pour faire ça et je ne le tiens
pas d avenir
oui vraiment vraiment et j'insiste dans
les 1200 postes je ne parle pas des
postes dédiés à la dgse et à landecy qui
ont chacun eu des budgets dans la
dernière loi de programmation et les
derniers événements dramatiques ont
donné ça il ya aujourd'hui 1200 postes
les les boîtes s'arrachent les gens pour
la cyber protection cas beaucoup de
choses à faire et que c'est une
véritable réflexion à mener la merci en
tout cas à mon 4 est revenu à porter cet
éclairage votre éclairage sur plateau de
7,8 société cette émission est
maintenant terminé merci votre attention
je vous retrouve dans 15 jours
votre soirée